[Musique]
laurent berger le secrétaire général de
la cfdt est l'invité d'auditions
publiques bonsoir bonsoir et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation celle des chaînes
parlementaires de la fp du figaro je
guette bien sûr les réactions des
internautes qui suivent cette émission
sur le site du journal sur le chat est
bien sûr je ferai état de vos
interrogations qui seront évidemment
répercuter immédiatement auprès de notre
invité de ce soir revendicatif mais avec
une image de sage laurent berger vous
avez condamné sans ambiguïté les
violences
vous dirigez désormais le premier
syndicat français votre voix compte même
si elle n'a peut-être pas été
suffisamment entendu par l'exécutif du
moins jusque là en tous les cas le
dialogue va s'établir tout à l'heure
avec le sénateur la république en marche
julien bargeton et puis le député
communiste stéphane peut vous répondrai
aux questions de rial mans de chaîner de
public sénat du new delhi et fo de super
assemblée nationale et puis tout de
suite de stéphanie le rouge de la sp et
de yves thréard du figaro 20 voilà
bonsoir à tous laurent berger vous
arrivez directement du séminaire de
rentrée du groupe des députés la
république en marche est ce que votre
présence parmi eux qui était très
apprécié et je crois de la part des élus
signifie que vous appuyez véritablement
fortement la démarche entreprise par le
chef de l'état donc ce grand débat pour
sortir de la crise des gilets jaunes
non mais d'abord la présence ma présence
ou celle de représentants de la cfdt
dans les groupes parlementaires à les
classiques elle s'opère à la république
en marche comme elle s'opère dans chez
les républicains
quand même sociales versées aux grands
témoins
les députés la république en marche ce
que je fais cette situation de crise
extrême ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que cette démarche elle est classique
d'aller 1 comme responsable syndical
s'est exprimée par un groupe sunnite et
les choses c'est vous qui avait lancé
l'idée du grand débat vous souvenez il
je mène ce qui est sûr répondre sur ce
grand débat sur ce grand débat c'est
dans l'adn de la cdt de débattre c'est
dans l'adn de la cfdt de saisir toutes
les occasions pour pousser ses
propositions et donc moi le courrier du
président de la république j'en ferais
pas l'exégèse je vais pas regarder ligne
par ligne à des choses que je n'aurais
pas écrit comme ça par exemple sur la
fiscalité ses marques et comment on fait
en sorte d'avoir des impôts moins élevés
comme moi j'aurais dit une fiscalité
plus juste
il ya d'autres sujets il ya la question
du pouvoir d'achat qui est quand même le
grand absent de cette lettre ceci étant
j'ai aussi entendu qui avait pas de
sujet interdit interdit et bien
puisqu'il n'y a pas de sujet interdit la
cfdt
oui elle compte s'y investir de
différentes manières par la présence de
ses adhérents le militant que l'on va
outillés pour ces grands débats pour
aller les travailleurs fall
organisez-vous par la capacité bien sûr
question vous pourriez être lié une
certaine manière co-organisateur
localement aa co-organisateur non mais
bon il ya un organisateur un
organisateur s'est il ya un organisateur
que le gouvernement avec des gars ont
l'état donnait pas les noms d'amis mais
il y a la capacité de toutes les
organisations syndicales associatives
les corps intermédiaires de se saisir de
ce débat pour il le compte pour
l'enrichir et on peut très bien débattre
entre nous débattre avec d'autres nous
allons les battre avec des asociaux
laurent berger vous participerez
activement vous même vous allez allez
oust pour discuter avec les français
d'abord nous on va discuter avec les
adhérents et militants cfdt puis on va
discuter aussi avec les organisations
associatives avec lesquels nous sommes
habitués de travailler plus d'autres on
a un collectif depuis maintenant un peu
plus de quatre ans qui s'appelle les
places de la république qui regroupe des
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
contre l'exclusion des associations
environnementales des mots des
mutualistes et centex arrivé tard ceux
des banques nous allons moi je
m'investirai we dance dans ce débat mais
d'abord pour porter les propositions et
la vision de la cfdt sur les différents
thèmes qui sont les gourmands qui est le
gouvernement est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a donné des garanties suffisantes
sur l'indépendance et sachant pour
l'instant vendredi le nom on a deux noms
ce sont deux ministres vendredi moi je
les dédie aux produits nice qui nous a
reçus il arrive aux syndicats les et des
employeurs et patronales pour la
réalisation de ce débat en demandant ce
qu'on en pensait j'avais dit qu'il
fallait deux grands deux grandes
conditions pour la tenue de ce n'est
qu'elle la première c'était les
conditions de tenue de ce débat de ces
débats c'est à dire j'avais dit il faut
de l'indépendance donc ça veut dire que
si les les coordinateurs son du
gouvernement ce qui est un peu
regrettable j'aurais préféré que ce soit
la cndp mais si les coordinateurs son du
gouvernement les garants doivent être
totalement indépendant pour vérifier la
loyauté de ce débat le deuxième élément
c'est qu'il faut que ces débats se
déroulent dans de bonnes conditions y
compris de conditions de débats et de
sentiments apaisé et la deuxième un
grand grand paquet de condition c'est
que du de ce type de débat il n'a de
sens que si in fine et ça ne se résume
pas à pas on vous fait un compte rendu
et on décida qu'elle reprenait dans un
bio il ya donc des pilotes
il ya deux pilotes gouvernement à margon
monsieur lecornu que vous n'avez rien à
dire contre eux donc quand vous savez
moi je n'ai jamais ressenti c'est parce
que vous l'avez nicole notât
et puis semblerait que ce soit pas
possible et on parle aussi de monsieur
bailly qui est l'ancien pdg de la ratp
pourquoi madame nota a été écarté de ce
casting
et puis vous savez il ya un truc c'est
au moins sur des chaînes comme les
autres on sait qu'on commente pas des
faits que nous donc madame nota elle
sera pas garantie apparemment c'est ce
qui est prévu
bon j'ai pas commenter pourquoi j'irais
une lettre dont on connaissait un pays
c'est quelqu'un avec qui on avait on a
l'habitude dé changer
il avait travaillé notamment un rapport
je crois sur le travail du dimanche dans
lequel on avait
pu échanger et faire valoir nos
propositions voilà c'est quelqu'un qui a
fait preuve de dialogue à leur gré
thèmes qui sont énumérés à une plus
d'une trentaine de questions qui sont
cités par le chef d'état il propose
notamment de réfléchir à la meilleure de
mieux organiser notre pacte social est
ce que vous pouvez faire une réponse sur
ce point
oui ça sera une réponse un peu de temps
parce que passer ou non mais organiser
de l'iddri vous inspire quoi
ça inspire qu' il faut savoir se comment
on protège les citoyens face à quels
risques entre guillemets donc la
question liée au parcours professionnel
à l'emploi au chômage à la formation
professionnelle les questions de
protection sociale plus classiques comme
la santé comme la prise en charge de la
famille comme la retraite etc
et puis il ya la question aujourd'hui on
le voit ce mouvement gilet jaune il est
né sur des mouvements des éléments
parfois périphériques à cet état indien
sociale le logement la qui sont des
transports la mobilité l'irrigation de
l'ex asi l'accessibilité il est pas d là
dessus mais on va y revenir si vous
voulez mais l'accessibilité
l'accessibilité l'accessibilité aux
services publics c'est donc le nouveau
pacte social s'est d'abord définir on a
besoin de se protéger de faire vivre
notre cohésion sociale sur quoi est le
deuxième élément c'est comment on
finance tout cela et qui doit financer
ce qu'elle était est-ce que vous sur la
fiscalité par exemple est ce que vous
regrettez qu'un point soit écartée c'est
celui de l'impôt sur la fortune
d'abord il est écarté parce que en même
temps que dix ans tous les sujets il y
aura un cas sujet interdit donc il est
vrai pour ceux qui veulent les quartiers
nord environ un pas en arrière si je
viens de voir d'arrivée devant les
députés en marche
moi je leur ai dit vous savez il ya les
totems la vie à l'essentiel l'essentiel
c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans notre
fiscalité pour qu'elle soit plus juste
il faut que les plus hauts revenus
contribuent davantage et c'est pas
forcément par les ss mais c'est très
relax a peut être parlé succession ça
peut être sur les successions ça peut
être sur une tranche d'impôt
supplémentaire glacerie aux revenus oui
ça peut être sûr revenir sur la flat tax
sur la détention et la barre
donc voyez pour que les plus hauts
revenus contribuent pour que la
fiscalité soit plus juste on a plusieurs
outils s'il faut laisser de côté un de
ses outils pour que les autres soient
plus efficaces encore su preneur
question stéphanie peut-être encore sur
la fiscalité
non moi j'avais une question sur le
conseil économique et social dont eric
woerth a suggéré qu'il organise le débat
justement est ce que vous serez punis
potez d'ailleurs le conseil économique
et social environnemental comme seul et
césaire qui sont équivalentes dans les
régions très bien ont beaucoup travaillé
sur un certain nombre de sujets peuvent
très bien contribuer à ce débat aurait
pu être l'organisateur c'est pas le
choix et non par exemple on a évoqué la
question de l'immigration l'intégration
si vous me permettez michel justement
puisque vous évoquez c'est eux c'est
vraiment le serpent de mer
ça fait partie des thèmes est ce qu'on
doit supprimer ses yeux pour le
remplacer peut-être par autre chose
il est même question puisque c'est sa
figure dans la lettre du président de la
république
on se doute il ya quelques doutes sur le
sénat le cel sénat sont elles des
chambres qu'il faut absolument conserver
ma conviction père des assemblées comme
arrive au derme par la conviction et oui
oui vous savez et puis je crois pas que
la crise que nous traversions la réponse
soit
que faut-il supprimer comme institution
à part faire des économies
oui enfin vous savez aujourd'hui je vais
vous dire franchement les choses comme
je le pense à ce moment où la démocratie
est en danger
moi quand je regarde les acteurs qui
avec des actes des désaccords profonds
sur les politiques à mener par
potentiellement mais les acteurs qui
peuvent être garant d'un certain nombre
de valeurs républicaines et d'autres
institutions
j'envoie un par exemple que le président
du sénat est donc heureusement qu'il
existe si je peux me permettre
et donc si vous voulez je vous appréciez
me chercher dans ce qu'il représente
comme capacité à toujours être égal sur
les valeurs les valeurs très faible des
eaux qu'il avait
et ça fait donc des longs premier samedi
de mobilisation vous avez senti non mais
je crois que vous savez dans cette dans
ce moment d'un peu de chaos
il faut être en capacité d'avoir des
responsables qui assument leur part de
responsabilité c'est vrai pour les
politiques c'est vrai pour les
organisations patronales et oui et donc
mais au-delà de ça il peut y avoir des
interrogations des évolutions sur les
chambres
il y avait une réforme constitutionnelle
qui se préparait elle disait elle
prévoyait de certaines évolutions du
conseil économique et social et
environnemental
donc on peut en discuter mais où ça il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'endroits où la
société civile puissent s'exprimer et le
cesa il a fait beaucoup de travail pour
commencer à réfléchir aux panels
citoyens par exemple au fait que les
citoyens s'invite beaucoup plus dans les
débats y compris du 16e et aussi de la
république et donc je crois que il faut
pas ce début de débat qui consisterait à
faire du tir au pigeon sur deux
institutions se serait produit total
vous craignez que les syndicats fassent
eux aussi les frais du débat puisque
c'est ce que certains membres du
gouvernement sans le dire c'est que les
corps intermédiaires qui sont très
attaquées
actuellement pourrait l'être aussi à la
faveur d'ela moi je connais des membres
du gouvernement qui tiennent ce discours
et puis à au premier problème sur tel ou
tel sujet font appel à l'expertisé des
organisations syndicales donc un peu de
sérieux moi les organisations syndicats
qui vont faire les frais de ce débat
soyons clair que c'est ce qu'ont pas de
propositions ce que n'ont pas d'idées
ceux qui vocifèrent et je parle pas
d'autres organisations syndicales
forcément clarifiant les ai marre les
partis d'extrême droite et d'extrême
gauche
surtout qu'à l'extrême droite peut être
très embêté dans ce débat s'il se
passait dans un cadre extrêmement apaisé
et dans lequel on pourrait on pouvait
discuter de façon apaisée
parce que moi je le dis une des
ambitions de la cfdt dans ce débat c'est
à chaque fois que tu auras une poussée
réactionnaire c'est de faire une poussée
humaniste et progressiste en classe et
donc je vous le dis les organisations
syndicales dans cette crise de la
représentation elles sont interrogées la
même manière que toutes les institutions
médias compris d'ailleurs mais donc
elles doivent travailler en interne pour
se rapprocher de leurs mandants
potentiel local cgt paris mais qui n'est
pas qui n'a pas qui ne possède à
matignon on vous l'avez vous y étiez
vous et je vois mais personnellement pas
sûr bon sport personnes
personnellement c'est une erreur car les
fenêtres sont ouvertes et bien quand les
fenêtres sont ouvertes pour discuter et
bien on discute et on passe par les
fenêtres pour essayer de pousser nos
propositions la cfdt n'a pas peur de ce
débat
elle a des propositions sur la fiscalité
elle a des propositions sur la
citoyenneté et la démocratie est la
décomposition sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
les services publics sur les territoires
et les fractures territoriales que
direz-vous sur l'immigration
l'immigration précisément vous aviez dit
au début de l'idée quand l'idée a été
émise du de ce grand débat que vous
aviez vous même lancé d'ailleurs cette
idée que l'immigration n'avait pas sa
place dans ce débat
or le président de la république écrit
clairement qu'il faut réfléchir qu'il
faut son réfléchir au sujet de
l'immigration il évoque même sans citer
le mot suggère même que le parlement
soit appelé tous les ans à voter des
quotas mois lorsqu'il a été il a démarré
cette idée de grands débats et le
gouvernement a dit il y aura
potentiellement est présent la preuve
est qu'il y aura potentiellement cinq
thèmes les claques thème retenu est
aujourd'hui plus sain qui est l
immigration en tant que tel moi j'ai dit
que c'était faux lit j'ai dit faute et
folie parce que dans le climat actuel
totalement je le dis un parfois
irrationnelle autour de l'immigration
faut savoir que les personnes qui sont
entrés illégalement sur le territoire
français était moins nombreuse l'année
passée quels étaient les années
précédentes donc à une part
d'irrationalité extrêmement forte qui
veut pas dire que ça pose pas un certain
nombre de sujets on peut y revenir si
vous m'en laisser le temps le j'avais
dit que c'était folie là dans la le
débat sur la citoyenneté et la
démocratie le m bah on va en discuter
puisque c'est me laurin discuter en
disant c'est quoi les données du
problème et vous aurez donné des ratés
de l'intégration le dit le cdh des
relations et des ratés d'intégration il
ya même les ratés du droit d'asile et a
même raté a su de l'accueil élémentaire
de droits humains et de la dignité
humaine dans notre pays oui elle est
ratée et oui il ya des sujets qui sont
posées sur les règles européennes comme
par exemple le règlement de dublin qui
fait qu'on a de plus en plus de
personnes qui sont en situation de no
man's land administratif parce que ils
sont entrés par un pays on les renvoie
dans ce pays ont ils tant qu'ils sont
pas dans ce pays on peut pas gérer leur
situation
donc ces questions la traite on les
mettrait ton lait en humanité traitons
l'est pas
laissant vociférer l'extrême droite sur
la question de l'immigration
vous aurez aussi des choses à dire sur
ce thème là les fans et autres geeks
étudié que vous souhaitiez que le débat
se passe de la manière la plus apaisée
poesy possible est ce que vous appelez à
ce que les manifestations cessent à
partir du moment où on entre dans le
temps du dialogue
d'abord j'en ai aucun pouvoir donc faire
des choses vont émettre un drap noir
mais je crois que il faudrait retrouver
les conditions d'un dialogue apaisé
c'est un dialogue où chacun s'écoute se
respecte et où on rentre dans une phase
de discussion et pas simplement
d'affrontements de à distance d'accord
enfin des actes samedi après samedi
enfin je pense que ça pourrait avoir du
sens ici le tout le monde rentrait dans
le vrai débat après c'est les gens qui
ont lancé souvent à qui il appartient de
le faire cesser
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut
qu'on sorte de cette situation où samedi
à samedi chacun attend s'interroge sur
ce qui va se passer
ce quel sera le degré de violence quelle
ce graal le degré de mobilisation le
week-end dernier c'était plus fort c'est
et 80000 personnes quand une
organisation syndicale fait un mouvement
national il ya 88 personnes dans les
rues beaucoup de quotidiens titre c'est
un échec
bon il faut pas ce que vous vivez vous
ces et le dimanche d'après les
mobilisations on commente pendant deux
jours et demi ce qui s'est passé le
samedi et on reprend la prévision pour
le samedi suivant
bravo la progression du débat
démocratique
bravo la progression du débat d'idées
donc moi je le vis comme ans oui j'ai
dessiné comme un simple citoyen c'est à
dire je m'informe d'accord je vis je
sors voilà je vais dire mais vous êtes à
gérer un recompte de gilet jaune pour le
oui dans certaines régions y'a pas de
leçon à donner
fait dans le gilet jaune il faut
distinguer faut distinguer ce qui
sincèrement vivent des situations qui
sont des inégalités qui sont
inacceptables
donc dont ils ne peuvent plus qu'ils ont
le sentiment parce que la fiscalité
s'est déplacée des entreprises vers les
ménages que ils n'en n'ont pas pour leur
argent parce que dans le même temps les
services publics ont déserté une partie
de leur territoire face heures il ya des
gens sincères art et que l'on entend que
l'on écoutait l'autre partie et l'autre
partie c'est des gens qui sortent sur
ces mécontentements qu'il faut il faire
pour qu'on sait bruit ou qui sont
violence encore pire et qui pousse
les feux à fond sur un affrontement pour
essayer de créer une sorte
d'internationale démocratie sociale
je vais vous dire oui bien sûr moi j'ai
de la compréhension pour ceux qui
expriment du mal être et qui voudrait
qu'on y trouve des réponses sociales
voire démocratique
j'ai de la condamnation pour ceux qui
pratiquent les violences j'ai aucune
espèce de sympathie pour tous que la
poussée réactionnaires qui est en train
de s'opérer dans le pays j'ai même dû de
la combativité vous passez du coup c'est
d'abord un mouvement d'extrême nord mais
en tout cas on le voit il y à un certain
nombre de propos de comportements qui
ont été faits cravate ou des extrêmes
d'extrême droite beaucoup d'extrême
gauche également oui mais je suis clair
là-dessus avoir de la sympathie pour des
gens qui sont proches ou qui ont exprimé
de la sympathie pour monsieur soral et
c'est moi je condamne ça c'est tout donc
tu vois pas pourquoi moi c'est ce dont
parlait françois ruffin non mais je m'en
fous de parler de tel ou tel je vous le
dis franchement je parle de ce qui est
en train de se passer c'est une poussée
réactionnaire un pays avec une vision
assez totalitariste des rapports
regardez ce qui se passe sur les
journalistes on pour que des députés
pour que tous ceux qui expriment une
nuance ou un désaccord sont pointés soit
par les réseaux sociaux soit par des
courriers c'est sincèrement il faut
arrêter d'être complaisant une question
importante comment on clôt ce débat
comment ça se passe est ce qu'il faut
faire
référendum à questions multiples pour
donner redonner la parole aux français
pour dire bon bah voilà c'est comme ça
qu'on va s'inscrire
elle et lui l'illustration de la volonté
du président de la république
d'instaurer entre lui et le peuple un
rapport direct avec une forme de
négation des corps intermédiaires sortir
de ces deux sets de cette ambiance en
pensant que c'est réinstaurer ce rapport
direct qui marcherait c'est une profonde
bêtise et ça ne marchera pas et on aura
un nouveau chaos
donc pas de référendum j'ai à vous dire
ce qu'il faut c'est une conférence un
grenelle de l'angle du pouvoir de vivre
ma conférence avec les partenaires
sociaux et les associations
mais c'est faux à chaque fois qu'on l'a
fait et dans les sorties des choses si
tant est qu'on veut bien regarder ce
qu'il en sort très bien mais pour cela
il faut avoir
du président de la république qu'est ce
que vous avez eu en fait un contact
puisque vous n'en avez pas depuis me
semble-t-il depuis la grand messe à
l'elysée dit déclaré peart journée non
mais non j'ai pas envie qu'à chaque fois
expliquer ce que sont mes points de vue
et les points de vue de la cfdt n'est
plus seulement la cfdt on n'en retienne
que j'ai eu ou pas le projet prévoit
également la formation toujours on
travaille on fait pas avoir ça va
falloir au premier ministre et au
ministre nos propositions et après vous
savez j'ai pas beaucoup de temps à
consacrer à autre chose donc s'il ya un
coup de fil durant un coup de fil mais
ce n'est pas l'essentiel très bien voilà
c'était un élément d'information quand
même merci à tous les deux aires pour
cette première partie est maintenant
nous accueillons donc les deux
parlementaires que je vous annonçais
tout à l'heure pour la deuxième partie
de l'audition publique
e bonsoir vos petites questions
d'internautes du figaro qui dit il ya eu
du retard à l'allumage de la cfdt pour
réagir dans la crise que traverse notre
pays ses bons sentiments
bah non j'ai un mois dès le premier
week-end où il ya eu des manifestations
j'ai proposé un pacte social de la
transition écologique donc voilà j'ai un
on est comme tout le monde on lie pas je
dis pas qu'on l'avait vu venir on avait
bien vu les crises sur lesquels ce
mouvement a prospéré
mais il n'y a pas eu de retard à
l'allumage au contraire je crois avec
nous donc que stéphane lebon soir vous
êtes député communiste de seine saint
denis et aux côtés le sénateur la
république en marche de paris julien
bargeton on pensera tous les deux je
peux vous avez une question directe à
poser sans doute à notre interlocuteur
ce soir la première question qui sera
laquelle ça n'intéresse d'interroger
laurent bergé s'est tu il ya une phrase
du président de la république lors de
ses voeux aux français c'est quelqu'un
d'assez peu reprise ensuite par les
commentateurs et qui pourtant moi m'a
marqué et je pense que le secrétaire
général de la cfdt aussi le président de
la république a déclaré que le
capitalisme ultralibéral et financier va
vers sa fin et alors personne n'a repris
cette phrase que g assez surprenante
dans la bouche des manuels macro vivait
plutôt comme étant l'incarnation de cet
ultralibéralisme est ce que vous vous
l'avez noté est-ce que vous en avez tiré
des enseignements ou des espérances pour
la suite d'abord moi mes espérances et
se traduise dans les actes après donc
j'attendrai de voir les acteurs mais ce
qui est sûr c'est que il ya une
aspiration un nouveau modèle de
développement basé à la fois sur la
transition écologique sur la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale des entreprises et sur
la justice sociale et donc je pense la
cfdt porte a depuis longtemps qu' il
faut il faut combattre une logique
purement financière que celle de
l'économie et qui était celle de
l'économie pendant trop longtemps qui
nous a fait connaître la crise que nous
avons connue en 2008 et qui finalement
n'a pas ne s'est pas arrangée
depuis malgré des corrections soi disant
apporter
donc il faut plus de partage de la
richesse il faut plus d'écouté des
différentes parties prenantes dans
l'économie et il faut également je crois
un modèle de développement productif
beaucoup plus respectueux de
l'environnement
si c'est ça et monsieur peu les
prochains vous entendez si c'est sa
qualité c'est ça qui a été si c'est
cette phrase elle voulait dire cela tant
mieux et je dis chiche mais ça se
construit ça sympa ça demande du temps
et du dialogue à la mer ne pensez vous
pas que la crise que connaît notre pays
aujourd'hui
et justement la crise d'un système
libéral auquel les politiques de droite
et de gauche sont quand même converti
ces 30 dernières années et qui est en
échec puisqu'il on a une économie une
production de richesse dans notre pays
qui progressivement rémunère davantage
de capital que le travail est faut-il
pas rééquilibré c'est sûr quand je dis
le partage de la richesse c était la
même dans les semaines à venir lancer
une campagne salaires dans les
entreprises on est là dessus mais c'est
cette crise elle et c'est assez
particulier quand même parce que certes
elle dit sans doute des choses sur un
mode de développement et sur une
interrogation est sans doute sur la
question de du surpoids des côtes du
financier par rapport à l'humain à
l'économie restera mais elle s'est pas
dirigé vers les entreprises soient elles
elles seraient dirigés vers l'état donc
vous savez je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses dans cette crise met dedans il ya
certainement le fait que le facteur
humain
le facteur environnemental et participe
particulièrement le facteur humain ne
sont pas assez considéré c'est en tout
cas ce que ce que laisse que les
citoyens ressentent les travailleurs et
les adhérents 16 et julien bargeton
laurent berger vous êtes désormais à la
tête de la plus importante organisation
syndicale de france au regard des
dernières élections professionnelles
selon le cevipof
les partis politiques inspirent
confiance à 12% alors les organisons les
organisations syndicales sont un petit
peu plus haute à 30% mais au regard des
autres pays européens
quelles seraient les propositions que
vous feriez finalement pour déjouer un
peu cette malédiction de la faiblesse du
syndicalisme français
est ce que vous allez en faire dans le
cas de ce grand débat national comment
finalement faire remonter ce que nous
souhaitons tous notamment le taux de
syndicalisation par exemple vous avez
moi je ne nie pas qu'il ya une crise de
la représentation qui touche
il conclut le syndicalisme ce serait
folie de nier ça par contre je pense
qu'on n'a aucun intérêt à se dire que le
quel est le moins considéré ou le moins
représentatifs des chiffres non mais
c'est vrai vous citer les chiffres
d'ailleurs vous avez eu l'honnêteté de
susciter le chiffre qui vise les
politiques et qui vise les syndicats
quand on regarde le taux de
participation aux élections et je suis
sur un mode la défensif et après je vais
vous dire que moi ça nous interroge ce
qu'on regarde les résultats aux
élections 50% en fonction publique c'est
trop peu mais c'est 50%
c'est pas le cas dans toutes les
élections politiques quand on a une
présence syndicale dans une entreprise
c'est autour de 60 65 % donc en fait
nous nos défis il est de deux heures
face à ces crises bad de ce que nous
disent la crise et gilet jaune 1
ces deux défis de la proximité parce que
pour pour être encore plus proche des
travailleurs s'implanter là où il n'est
pas présent
puis le deuxième c'est la capacité de
faire entendre des réalités humaines
beaucoup plus fortement vous savez le
les syndicalistes souvent il ya un
problème dans une entreprise dans un
champ professionnel
ben on essaie de trouver la solution il
faut laisser la phase de l'expression de
cette difficulté je vais vous dire un
exemple on a découvert certains auraient
découvert dans cette crise que il y
avait beaucoup de femmes avec des
enfants et qu'ils aient des femmes
seules
cette réalité là les organisations
syndicales la connaissent depuis
longtemps et la porte depuis longtemps
de telle sorte qu'ils y compris à la caf
les élus locaux sis dans les élus locaux
exactement mais de telle sorte que
mental de telle sorte qu'à la caf la
caisse d'allocations familiales dans les
orientations de la caf les organisations
syndicales ont porté une attention
particulière en direction de ces
familles monoparentales donc ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que tout ça doit
nous interroger
quand on n'arrive pas à se faire
entendre d'interlocuteurs politique
voire patronaux et que là ce mouvement
ado les sentiments qui rendait plus
vivant c'est des réalités que nous
portions de skis est pas aussi un sujet
on y viendra peut-être après sur le fait
que nous on a tous été impactés par le
numérique
on parle beaucoup de lui mais risation
de l'économie lumière isation des partis
politiques comment la cfdt réagit aussi
à ça moi ça m'intéresse beaucoup sur
notamment ce que ça pose sur
l'encadrement vous êtes assez fort dans
l'encadrement
et notamment la structure hiérarchique
est perturbée par le numérique mais
aussi sur d'autres sujets les nos modes
de dialogue
regardez mode et la bonne nouvelle dans
les enquêtes cevipof c'est que les
réseaux sociaux sont très mal considérés
aussi ouvrir parce que regarder comment
débat regardez la capacité qu'on a tous
les trois là à discuter mais vous n'êtes
pas d'accord sur tout et c'est bien
normal dans une démocratie quand nous
nos si on le faisait par réseaux sociaux
internes interposés on se lanceraient
des anathèmes à la figure on se lancera
des caricatures et des slogans
et là on parle de quoi est ce qu'on peut
et est-ce qu'il ya des sujets sur
lesquels on peut discuter et donc moi je
crois qu'il faut retrouver de la
délibération collective
il faut remettre du débat citoyen
politique dans les territoires c'est un
enjeu que nous a semblé t on porte qu'on
est en train d'organiser avec nos unions
locales départementales je sais que
d'autres parce que quelque part il ya
aussi une faillite du collectif
ce mouvement c'est quand même le jeu et
moi alors bien sûr sacré de la
fraternisation de stars et l'enjeu de
nos organisations en tout cas de la
série tu essaies de passer du je au nous
ça veut pas dire qu'on est le jeu mais
ça veut dire que le nous on crée du
collectif et ça pour ça il faut débattre
il faut discuter et y compris la société
civile il faut qu elle s'accepte comme
diverses contradictoires et ça fait pas
de nous des ennemis jeudi un bar de
touristes c'est un des enjeux du débat
public
est ce que vous regrettez que président
de la république on en a parlé mais
l'exécutif dans son ensemble on a
également entendu le premier ministre
sur ce sujet n'ait pas saisi la main
tendue par notre invité ce soir laurent
berger quant à le regretter parce que je
ne veux pas regarder le passé belles
heures au berger c'est un peu l'homme
qu'il nous faut ils nous ont dit lors du
séminaire de rentrée
bah c'est très bien je le rends berger a
été invitée lors du séminaire de rentrée
des députés moi je m'en réjouis et
maintenant tournons tous vers le grand
débat et sur le fond des sujets il
il a évoqué les territoires la façonne
la démocratie sociale la démocratie
représentative et j'aurai une question
mais c'était peut-être aussi des
positions la cfdt parce que ça interrogé
beaucoup la mobilité en matière de
déplacement si vous pouviez nous
préciser prime ou pas primes etc
télétravail enfin quelques éléments sur
la mobilité ça m'intéresse beaucoup
d'avoir vos propositions
nous nous pour aller très vite et pour
laisser monsieur peut s'excuser
prime transport prime transport
normalement cette prime elle est prévue
genou on pousse les négociations des
plans de déplacements en entreprise pour
regarder comment ça peut s'organiser et
si papa négociation de plans déplacement
qui permet la prise en charge de
transport d'organes sont des transports
collectifs cetera moi je suis fils d'un
ouvrier qui étaient ramassés par par
l'entreprise ramasser cimentant il va
mais par l'entreprise lorsque au bout de
notre eu ça n'existe plus on forêt
hantée truc si patsy pas de plan de
déplacement d'entreprise aide au
transport prime transport payer
obligatoirement par l'entreprise
stéphane peu une question d'un autre
ordre
cette crise est une crise où s'est
exprimé beaucoup de malaise autour du
pouvoir d'achat manière générale de la
justice sociale je sais la cfdt comme un
étant un syndicat jël expérimenté dans
des fonctions antérieures à un syndicat
très impliquée sur les problématiques du
logement et notamment dans les
organismes paritaires qui gère le
logement ou dans les caf dans la lettre
d' emmanuel macron le logement n'est
traité que sous l'angle de la transition
énergétique pas du tout sous l'angle de
la question du pouvoir d'achat
or toutes les études montrent que ces
dix dernières années la part que le
logement a pris dans le budget des
ménages a été le principal facteur de la
dégradation du pouvoir d'achat
quel que soit le statut des personnes
locataires ou propriétaires ne pensez
vous pas que ce grand débat doit être
l'occasion de maths à plat la politique
du logement et de dire au gouvernement
que pour l'instant sur ce sujet il fait
fausse route et qu'il fera mieux
regarder du côté d'autres pays européens
qui relance des grands plans
d'investissements publics par exemple
pour faire face à la crise du logement
dans leurs pays respectifs
je pense à deux pays qui sont pas du
tout très éloigné de nous je pense à
l'allemagne qu'il l'a fait au mois de
septembre ou adam le ter au mois
d'octobre
trois éléments sont logement d'abord il
y a eu vendredi dernier s'est passé sous
le radar évidemment mais un plan d'accès
au logement de 9 milliards parce que
vous êtes un ancien liste % logement
neuf milliards toutes les organisations
syndicales et patronales étaient
d'accord avec ce plan qui vise notamment
à une relance de la construction et à
une relance de la rénovation aussi dont
on a bien besoin
dans certains quartiers de l'habitat de
l'habitat social notamment
donc là il ya un vrai plan
d'investissement et pour le coût est
compris dans les outre-mer et tous et
pour le coup il ya un vrai effort public
les partenaires sociaux alors c'est le
deuxième et des morts parce que celle
observée les mains sales moi je crois
qu'il faut un encadrement des loyers
dans un certain nombre de zones tendues
je pense qu'il faut aller aller vers ça
puis troisième élément et c'est là où
c'est dans la lettre mais vous savez la
rénovation thermique des logements qui
est un double enjeu en termes de
logement mais en or en termes aussi de
précarité énergétique
on avait un plan de 500 milles et on a
quatre moins de 80 milles qui ont été
faits donc là il faut et ça c'est de la
création d'emploi local avec de la
formation et durable eh bien il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin là dessus mais
vous avez raison
le logement c'est aujourd'hui le
problème numéro un de beaucoup de
familles qui ont du mal à se loger et du
coup il faut sans doute aller encore
beaucoup plus loin
mais là pour le coup le plan
d'investissement 9 milliards qui suffira
pas et qui ne risquez pas de
l'investissement public est ce que j'ai
l'investissement des entreprises des
entreprises aidées ou et darche est
arrivé ça que c'est du salaire pour
garder une impression la semaine
dernière que c'était un plan d'entre eux
la même idée titre s'était il pas trop
là non c'est un plan paritaire et du
gouvernement sur l'investissement parce
que il ya aussi un investissement du
gouvernement
mais c'est aussi dans l'entreprise que
se joue la responsabilité donc c'est
normal aussi qu'ils puissent avoir des
solutions là dessus vous êtes j'ai posé
une question un peu large tout à l'heure
sur le télétravail
une étude montre qu'en ile-de-france 20%
des emplois peuvent faire l'objet de
télétravail et en même temps on dit que
c'est parfois une coupure avec la
collectivité des collègues et c'est
évidemment dommage parce qu'on sait très
bien qu'il ya un effet machine à café
comme on dit c'est à dire que les idées
elles s'échangent de façon à former
quelle est la position actuelle de la
cfdt nous on essaie de négocier des
plantes et des plantes télétravail faut
pas que ce soit toute la semaine
et il faut qu'ils aient des conditions
de travail on soit attentif sur les
conditions de travail des gens qui sont
télétravail sur l'histoire machine à
café qu'il faut développer des espaces
de coworking à quelques entreprises on a
signé des accords qui ont créé pour
imager des choses je dirais en bout de
ligne rer mais à certains endroits des
espaces de co2 de travail pour leurs
salariés qui leur permet d'aller dans
une relation de travail
mais en même temps ne pas faire nos
concerts les toutes les études sur les
salariés en ile de france montrent que
les gens alors c'est pas vrai qu'en ile
de france et que les gens en ont assez
de du transport qui se rajoute à la
journée de travail donc nous les
favorable mais il faut que ce soit
encadré il faut que ce soient négociées
ou savez c'est comme tout quand on
négocie en principe les salariés ils
négocient des choses qui leur avons
plutôt bien donc mais le treillis
travail c'est une bonne chose mais en
même temps ça faisait bloc pas assez il
faut que ce soit encadré
c'est un peu oui il ya le gouvernement
et le président de la république le
reprendre en salle est utilise souvent
la une formule pour expliquer sa
politique il faut que le travail paie
mais connaissez vous une autre façon de
rémunérer le travail que le salaire or à
la question de l'augmentation du smic au
mois de décembre le gouvernement a
préféré répondre par la prime d'activité
qui n'est pas le salaire qui est une
allocation non mais qu est une
allocation
or ne vous pensez vous pas que il est
une question majeure posées autour de la
question des salaires et de la part de
la rémunération du travail dans la
production de richesse d'une part et ne
faut-il pas premier geste faire une
augmentation de produire une
augmentation du smic il faut une
politique salariale beaucoup plus
redistributif qu'elle l'est aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que la cfdt a semaines qui
viennent elle va lancer une campagne
salaires le smic c'est un élément de
salaire minimum de démarrage et le
problème du smic principal c'est que les
gens il reste toute leur vie ou 13 très
longtemps alors que le l'enjeu il est
une progression le salaire ça doit être
ça le smic ça va être un salaire
d'entrée pour une faible qualification
ou une absence de qualification et
ensuite les lycées il faut négocier dans
les entreprises et dans les branches et
particulièrement dans les bons je suis
encore en augmentation
oui on est vertueux d'un écrasement son
augmentation elle est aussi un effet
d'écrasement des grilles salariales
qu'on n'arrive pas sur lequel on
n'arrive pas mais le smic le smic
aujourd'hui c'est au tour de 1200 un peu
moins 1200 euros moi je vous répondrais
que je crois que je vais vous dire
marron les questions elle sait que le
smic on y est un nom et on n'y est pas
plus c'est ça la réalité c'est qu'à
chaque le nombre de salariés va en
sortir
non mais non c'est pas qu'on espère que
ça va en sortir c'est qu' il faut une
politique salariale dans les entreprises
serrent que ya une espèce de feignantise
et de paresse a considéré que le smic
serait l'élément déterminant des
rémunérations dans notre pays c'est pas
vrai l'élément déterminant c'est la
négociation
dna dans les haies now dégâts ce n'est
que ce soit obligatoire et la
négociation dans les branches et donc
évidemment qu'il faut qu'ils soient
revalorisés tous les ans pour pas que
les salariés au smic voient leur pouvoir
d'achat stagner ou le feu
oui mais ça peut ça peut exister mais
c'est pas objectivement le truc c'est
que on aura fait quoi quand on aura fait
3 % de kusmi coup de pouce au smic
devait être j'ai très clair on aura on
n'aura pas réduit la difficulté des
progressions de salaires et de la fête
que la richesse est pas également
répartis dans l'entreprise moi je crois
à la politique salariale plus juste à
propos de sur une longue
à propos des échelles de salaire en 68 2
lors des accords de grenelle patronat de
l'époque par la voie du cnp est
considéré comme une proposition
acceptable une échelle des salaires dans
les entreprises de 1 à 20 68 aujourd'hui
on est dans une échelle de salaire de 1
à 2000 âgés ou faire un tri contre ils
vont reprendre à notre compte
la proposition du cnpe de 68 dans une
échelle de salaires différents cela
j'allais être utile c'est vous dire la
semaine dernière quand on a discuté avec
le ministère de l'économie
on lui a dit dans la loi pas que c'est
pas fini et il y aura un avant et un
après gilet jaune faut vous entendiez
des choses qui sont inacceptables
il faut revenir un encadrement des
rémunérations et à et des échelles de
rémunération plus juste dans
l'entreprise une échelle parce
qu'aujourd'hui
ministre d'économie pour nous le maire a
dit que les écarts de salaire de 200 à
300 il n'est pas allé pas de 2000 comme
je peux vous les avez trouvés mais ça va
peut-être existé un peu l'écart bruno le
maire dit des acteurs 623 chance c'est
qu'il accepta mai mais parce que parce
que vous savez ce que nous disent ces
crises c'est qu'il ya des choses qui
sont même si elles sont dix fois peuvent
paraître symbolique qui sont
inacceptables et lorsque vous avez une
progression des seins des hanches des
patrons du cac 40 sur l'année dernière
qui est autour de 14% et celle des
salariés qui est autour de 1,3 pour cent
et bien c'est inacceptable ça veut pas
dire je suis pas un naïf j'ai fait de
l'économie
mais vous savez pas dire que c'est comme
ça c'est un tuyau odile uhlrich il faut
oui bien sûr dans la loi pacte on lui a
pas plus que 10 on lui a fait une
proposition ce week-end
il faut davantage de transparence sur
les rémunérations et limiter les plus
hautes rémunérations des députés
communistes lors de la loi de racler
recettes fois habité whaou
le parti connaît ce qui se donne raison
au patronat de 1900 sera ça renvoie aux
sujets comme de l'entreprise c'est que
la responsabilité de distribuer du
pouvoir d'achat ça se fait quand même
dans l'entreprise on appelle toujours au
gouvernement au gouvernement
gouvernement mais il ya quand même leur
entrepôt de l'entrepôt de l'entreprise
comment appréciez-vous dans cette
période finalement l'attitude du
patronat ou des organisations
professionnelles
moi j'ai été assez je vous le dit assez
surpris à la fois par l'entretien de
monsieur roux de bézieux dans le
parisien ou par ce qu'a dit ce qu'est ce
qui a été dit dans la grande
distribution
est ce que vous trouvez que
les représentants des entreprises ont
été à la hauteur de cette crise comment
jugez vous si vous pouvez le faire
leur prise de position ou absence
d'opposition entreprises les entreprises
et leurs représentants donc les
agressions patronales elles ont bien vu
que le tir était pas dirigés vers elle
voces et se sont comportées voilà je
veux pas pourquoi c'est maintenant le
truc c'est qu'il ya un les rémunérations
et de il ya d'autres éléments que j'ai
pas cité c'est que il ya un effet de
transformation du cs un double versement
eh bien je crois qu'il serait légitime
que les entreprises assument davantage
de responsabilité sociale et
environnementale est dans la
responsabilité sociale et à leur gauche
il ya création d'emplois l' embauche de
jeunes en alternance
il ya la question la répartition de la
richesse et de l'investissement et c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut aller vous avez
répondu sur le smic et sur le sur le gel
du point d'indicé des fonctionnaires
banking nous nous sommes opposés au gel
du point d'indicé fonctionnaire je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
revendications sur la question salariale
des fonctionnaires alors il ya aussi un
accord qu'on a signé la cfdt
sous le précédent quinquennat qui
s'appelle ppcr carrière et rémunérations
l'évolution des carrières
si tout le monde l'avait signé il serait
appliquée beaucoup plus rapidement et de
gloire n'aurait pas prévu ni reculer
avec une réforme de la fonction publique
aussi voilà ça va c'est terminé on va en
parler justement de la réforme de la
fonction publique dans la dernière
partie de cette émission merci monsieur
c'était notre grand débat nous a tout de
suite pour la suite avec nos deux
journalistes qui arrive
avec nous donc organes mancini de public
sénat et ludovic faut de lcp assemblée
nationale bonsoir à tous les d'une
petite question d'un internaute du
figaro laurent berger certes vous vous
dirigez le premier syndicat de france
mais cet internaute s'interroge sur ce
que représente vos adhérents par rapport
aux forces vives du pays dit ça fait que
3 % alors qu'elle est votée à l'été
ouais bien sûr mais tout confondu les
adhérents de la cfdt s'est passé plus
que tout confondu tous les partis
politiques
donc c'est trop faible moi j'étais moi
vous savez je suis bien placé pour
savoir que la cfdt a beaucoup de
progression à faire et en nous en nos
ambitions fixées au congrès ces dix pour
cent adhérents en plus dans les derniers
trois années qui viennent mais à
déconsidérer en permanence la légitimité
la représentativité des corps
intermédiaires qui pour autant le son à
travers l'élection ont fait mal à la
démocratie
donc oui on avoue rené pas suffisamment
nombreux en terme d'adhérents mais si le
critère c'est seulement le nombre
d'adhérents il n'y a aucune force
politique et syndical autre qui est
capable de dire qu'elle est
représentative
oriane quand même remercier quand vous
voyez quand de moelle et gilet jaune ont
obtenu plus qu'aucun syndicat ces
dernières années est ce que vous ne vous
dites pas que les syndicats et leur mode
d'action aujourd'hui sont dépassés non
mais c'est pas les modes les modes
d'action du syndicalisme nous nous
interrogeons au dessus ça veut pas dire
qu'il est dépassé et sa vie mais ça veut
dire que la seule manifestation ne peut
suffire mais vous savez ce qui s'est
passé sur le fait qu'ils ont obtenu plus
comme vous dites en en deux en deux mois
que les syndicats ces dernières années
d'abord un c'est faux en partie je vais
vous dire pourquoi tout à l'heure 2
c'est ça doit interroger l'interlocuteur
gouvernementale le gouvernement pourquoi
il a cédé parce qu'il ya de la violence
c'est très interrogeant quand même sur
notre modèle démocratique pourquoi il
n'a pas fait confiance à la démocratie
sociale je vous prends un exemple la csg
pour les retraités
toutes les organisations syndicales de
retraités les associations de retraités
disait qui est le seuil de 1200 et eva
trop bas était inacceptable
on l'a dit on à manifester on a fait des
rassemblements on a rencontré les
députés etc
ils n'ont rien voulu entendre et en mois
et demi il cède sur ce enfin enfin mais
pourquoi donc ça veut dire que je crois
qu'il faut réinventer la démocratie et
puis ensuite les organisations
syndicales
comparer une entreprise où les
organisations syndicales sont présentes
même taille même secteur d'activité avec
une ou les organisations syndicales ne
sont pas présentes et cfdt ou pas cfdt
la situation des travailleurs n'est pas
la même regardez la situation des
personnes des salariés du privé qui
depuis maintenant quelques années on
leur complémentaire santé payé à 50% par
l'employeur leur employeur dans le privé
moi j'ai été dans ces deux situations
salariés non dont la mutuelle été nommé
en charge est pris en charge ça fait un
vrai gain de pouvoir d'achat bien au
delà sur l'année de ce qui a été accordé
donc ça veut dire que notre fille
interrogée pour nous aussi c'est notre
capacité à rendre visibles les résultats
qu'on n'obtient pas les travailleurs
vous aviez un mot à dire sur ce qui est
visible justement c'est des fameux 10
milliards d'euros ne s'est débloqué par
l'état suite à la crise des déchets
n'est joué bien sûr qu'il ya sur ces
interrogeant non non je ne veux pas le
minorer je vous savez je dis non je dis
que c'est d'un seul coup un coin dans le
dogme budgétaires qui ont été
omniprésents par ce gouvernement depuis
maintenant un mois un an et demi et que
ça arrive quelques semaines après une
lettre de cadrage assurance chômage où
il aurait fallu trouver jeudi il aurait
fallu parce qu'on les trouvera pas c'est
évidemment impossible 3 8 milliards
d'euros
donc ce que je dis c'est que c'est pas
négligeable pour les personnes vous
savez moi je suis mon histoire mon
origine me fait dire que je ne méprise
ray jamais un gain de pouvoir d'achat de
100 euros
même si c'est pas la prime d'actualité
pour un ménage modeste je ne méprise ray
jamais quand on va pouvoir bénéficier et
nous on essaye de pousser dans les
entreprises pour que la prime
défiscaliser bénéficiera au maximum de
salariés elle devrait bénéficier aussi
aux agents publics qui ne comprennent
pas pourquoi il n'en bénéficieraient pas
et donc oui il ya des mesures et elles
sont à prendre
est-ce que structurellement ça change la
question du partage de richesse
d'entreprises longuement donc ça suffit
pas il faut aller plus loin vous
l'évoquez à l'instant
la relation entre le gouvernement et les
partenaires sociaux il ya deux mois et
loire philippe vous opposer une fin de
non recevoir votre main tendue expliqué
que ce qu'attendaient les gilet jaune
c'était pas une grande conférence
nationale entre les partis politiques
les syndicats etc
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que le
climat a changé aujourd'hui le président
du groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée dit on a besoin de laurent
berger alors à presque 1 après avoir été
maltraités vous craignez d'être d'être
récupérée de servir de caution
vous savez la façon dont est traitée ou
maltraitées laurent berger ça assez peu
d'intérêt
je le dis comme ça parce qu'il n'est pas
une question de personnes dans tout ça
est une question de situation sociale et
de citations démocratique
ce qui est sûr c'est que ça a changé
pourquoi parce que la situation a empiré
et donc on continue d'avoir des
amertumes potentiellement mais ça sert à
rien les amertumes donc à cette marche
n'était pas une main tendue c'était une
proposition syndicale
cette proposition syndicale elle n'a pas
été retenue maintenant il ya un grand
débat qui s'ouvre est la façon la façon
dont il va se conclure pour travailler
sur des propositions c'est ça qui
m'intéresse maintenant la façon dont il
va se mener
on va prendre toutes parts je les dis la
façon dont il va se conclure en lien
avec les organisations syndicales les
associations il aurait son patronale etc
et donc je crois que ce gouvernement il
est en prise de conscience que allez je
l'avais déjà d'y aller tout seul on va
plus vite mais on va beaucoup moins loin
et on arrivait au moment où c'est on est
beaucoup plus loin où il faudrait aller
et il peut plus aller tout seul
donc s'il veut sortir et aller tout seul
à se planter et moi ça me fait pas
marrer ça me fait pas marrer ne vois pas
ce que je suis partisan mais ça me fait
pas marrer parce que notre pays en
souffrira démocratiquement et si on veut
aller plus loin avec les gens qui sont
élus le façon totale totalement légitime
pour aller au bout d'un mandat
eh bien il va falloir qu'il fasse avec
les acteurs sociaux la société civile et
dans ces cas-là cdt a répond présente
parce qu'elle est soucieuse de l'intérêt
des travailleurs et de l'intérêt général
lors déjà aller plus loin vous souhaitez
après le grand débat national
un grenelle du pouvoir de vivre c'est
votre expression concrètement qu'est ce
que ça veut dire est ce que c'est juste
une autre façon de parler du pouvoir
d'achat ou est-ce que c'est autre chose
c'est plus que le pouvoir d'achat c'est
le pouvoir de vivre c'est avoir les
moyens de vivre correctement
en terme donc de pouvoir d'achat c'est à
voir l'accessibilité pour au service
public c'est d'avoir des moyens de
mobilité adapté c'est avoir un logement
un appareil est tout à leur correcte
c'est d'avoir un système de soins qui
n'est pas éloigné où il faut pas
attendre des plombes et des plombs pour
avoir un rendez-vous voire même avoir un
désert médical autour de chez soi ils
essaient de pouvoir être reconnu
s'exprimer vous savez il ya un truc qui
a fait du mal dont on n'a pas vu c'est
la suppression des emplois aidés s'était
vu de façon arithmétique et budgétaires
et les personnes qui étaient en emploi
aidé au delà de l'amélioration de leur
situation peut-être pour se réinsérer
s'insérer sur le marché du travail je
connais bien le sujet j'étais conseiller
en insertion professionnelle
c'était aussi des gens qui crée du lien
social parce que c'était nous dit ce
mouvement si aussi qu'on a besoin de
revenir à une des valeurs de notre
république et la fraternité et le
pouvoir de vivre c'est aussi ça c'est
aussi la capacité à créer du lien à
avoir des espaces et c'est pour ça que
nous on plaide par exemple pour un
budget citoyens dans les territoires
pour que les gens puissent s'organiser
pour mener un projet collectif
donc c'est tout ça grondait du pouvoir
de vivre c'est recréer du lien recréer
du pouvoir d'achat recréer des
conditions de vie correcte de l'art
consiste de la considération pour chaque
citoyen et pour ça ça se fera
collectivement nous allons vous parler
des emplois aidés mais ce qu'ils sont
posé la question est-ce qu'ils sont
encore aussi justifié aujourd'hui quand
on voit nombre de chefs d'entreprise
laurent berger qui n'arrivent pas à
embaucher les contrats aidés ils
pouvaient très bien ils peuvent très
bien être dans le privé s'était passé
était aussi dans le secteur marchand
donc pour des personnes qui sont en
difficulté d'insertion professionnelle à
retrouver du travail à se réinsérer dans
le monde professionnel et bien les
contrats aidés peuvent très bien c'est
les entreprises ont du mal à se
à recruter dans un certain nombre de
secteurs ça veut dire qu'il ya une
interrogation avoir sur la formation
mais comme on a mis un peu le système un
peu en tension par par des modifications
pas forcément assez réactif aujourd'hui
et puis il ya aussi une question de
l'alternance d'apprentissage etc
geiger les entreprises ne font pas
suffisamment d'efforts autour de ça et
puis de mobilisation des acteurs
je rappelle que par exemple un certain
nombre de jeunes continuent les
discriminer aujourd'hui parce qu'ils
habitent pas au bon endroit parce qu'ils
n'ont pas la bonne couleur de peau parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le bon nom et là il ya
aussi un effort à faire c'est pour ça
que nous avons proposé nous au patronat
de mener une discussion sur les
discriminations la lutte contre les
discriminations dans l'emploi ou
l'inclusion peu importe comment on
appelle ça de ce l'on se trouve
mais pour qu'on traite ces questions là
parce que il n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas
de fatalisme à la aux problèmes de
recrutement va parler des réformes à
venir et notamment la réforme de
l'assurance chômage vous en parler un
petit peu tout à l'heure le gouvernement
vos demandes
près de 4 milliards d'économies pour
vous c'est un chiffre réaliste oui si
totalement irréaliste c'était irréaliste
avant cette crise et gilet jaune je vous
rapelle que au moment ils nous demandent
ça le gouvernement on a déjà un accord
depuis novembre dernier donc novembre
2017 qui s'applique ou à peu près
parents ont fait 800 millions
d'économies ce qui est énorme
d'ailleurs 2018 si même fin 2017 il ma
mémoire est bonne c'était déjà le
quinquennat de monsieur macron qui avait
lui qui avait dit au début on touchera
une fois à chaque sujet pas deux un an
après ils nous demandent de renégocier à
3 milliards 8 milliards d'économies
c'est irréaliste
sauf à empiéter à faire très très mal
aux demandeurs d'emploi en terme
d'indemnisation il en est hors de
question pour la cfdt
donc on est engagés dans cette
négociation on veut la réussir on va là
réussir autour de plusieurs ambitions la
première c'est de maintenir un niveau
d'indemnisation pour les demandeurs
d'emploi je rappelle que l'indemnisation
moyenne c'est 1020 euros
1020 euros que 95 % des chômeurs
indemnisés son maximum à 2000 euros
donc ça ça relativise les chômeurs qui
en profitera donc l'indigo indemnisation
un accompagnement beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup plus fort y compris pour faire
face aux pénuries de recrutement et
l'accompagnement des salariés et des
demandeurs d'emploi vers un certain
nombre de ses emplois et une
responsabilisation des entreprises sur
l'utilisation des contrats courts
on est en train de négocier c'est
difficile il y aura pas un accord si
c'est pas un scoop
n'y aura pas un accord à 3 8 milliards
d'économies c'est sûr vous voulez la
réussir mais ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement lui cherche à la faire
échouer pour reprendre la main ça c'est
l'avant et après maintenant si ils le
faisaient
et s'ils le faisaient en voulant faire
ces 3 8 milliards d'économies
il faudrait qu'ils expliquent aux
demandeurs d'emploi dont je rappelle
l'immense majorité va pas au bout de ses
droits et retrouver un emploi avant ce
qu il a plus de la moitié cumul ou la
moitié cumule une activité en même temps
qu'elle indemnisées parce que c'est des
activités réduit faudra qu'il explique
qui leur fait mal je suis pas sûr que ce
soit dans le ton de ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui
voyons il a la puissance aujourd'hui au
gouvernement d'aller dans ce sens là non
mais moi je crois ce que les partenaires
sociaux ils sont légitimes ils ont
prouvé leur responsabilité dans le
système de l'assurance chômage
même si on aurait pu faire mieux parfois
en jouant à contre cycle pour mettre
plus de réserves
au moment où ça allait mieux dans
l'économie peu importe maintenant on en
est là donc il faut que les oreillers
sont syndicales et patronales
s'entendent sur un accord avec l'armée
de continuer à faire vivre un système
d'assurance chômage qui si on l'avait
pas pour le rouge red tout un tas de
gens dans la pauvreté encore là je
tentais en termes de calendrier ces
négociations entre partenaires sociaux
devaient en principe aboutir le mois
prochain en février est ce que ça vous
semble réaliste est ce que il faut
terminer cette négociation avant même la
fin du grand débat national qui peut
comporter un certain nombre de
réflexions sur ces sujets je pense qu'il
faut un bon accord l'accord équilibré
avec une responsabilité des uns et des
autres s'il faut de quinze jours de plus
il faudra quelques jours de plus et la
ministre du travail lors de ses voeux
aujourd'hui a dit que la question
n'était pas tant le le moment où il y
aura un accord c'est que la capacité à
trouver un accord donc on va se
concentrer sur le qualitatif et le
quantitatif et le temporel
on va laisser un peu de côté pour rester
sur l'ambition d'un régime d'assurance
chômage qui protège correctement et qui
aident à retrouver du travail mais c'est
du temps alors justement autre réforme
des retraites prochaines réformes à
venir potentiellement explosif est ce
que là vous pensez que le gouvernement
va pouvoir la mener à son terme et dans
le calendrier prévu à savoir 2010
mais oui il peut la mener à son terme
s'il en fait une réforme de progrès
social c'est chez nous pour l'instant on
peut pas savoir
mais nous on fait partie de ceux qui
pensent on
qu'une réforme des retraites systémique
et générateur de progrès pourquoi parce
qu' aujourd'hui lorsqu'on est une femme
on est sanctionné où on arrive à la
retraite
lorsqu'on est un jeune qui a commencé ou
un moins jeune au cours de sa carrière
qui a commencé par beaucoup de précarité
on est sanctionné lorsqu'on a commencé à
travailler jeunes
on cotise encore plus longtemps que ceux
qui ont 4 commence à travailler plus
tard donc on peut mettre de la justice
sociale à tous les étages
y compris en revoyant ce qu'on appelle
les avantages familiaux pour que ce soit
plus adapté aux réalités familiales aux
réalités de travail d'aujourd'hui
donc oui le gouvernement il peut aller
au bout
s'il continue la méthode qu'elle est là
qu'il a emprunté pour le port jusqu
alors et qu'on salue qu'une méthode de
vraie concertation où chaque
organisation peut arriver avec ses
propositions qui sont débattues et si
c'est pas une réforme pour faire moins
mais une réforme pour faire mieux je
rappelle que les systèmes de retraite
arrive petit à petit l équilibre et donc
ça doit pas être une réforme
paramétrique budgétaire c'est une
réforme qualitative
sinon si la logique est laid on sert un
peu les boulons évidemment que le
contexte sera plus compliqué en 2015
vous aviez co signé un accord concernant
les retraites complémentaires avec un
système de malus pour inciter les
salariés à prolonger un petit peu leur
carrière aujourd'hui même qu'à entrer en
application d'ailleurs de vos débuts
voilà aujourd'hui certains articles
semblent laisser entendre que la cfdt
regrette
cet accord est ce que c'est le cas la
cfdt à l'époque elle faisait face comme
tous ceux qui gèrent le régime des
retraites complémentaires
un profond déficit qui faisaient que
pour l'agirc l'art caisse des retraites
des cadres il y avait potentiellement
une incapacité à les payer à partir de
en tout cas de les payer sur toute la
durée d'une année donc dans ces cas là
quand on gère les choses on assume ses
responsabilités et puis la situation
financière s'améliore s'est grandement
améliorée et on est en train de discuter
de la mise en place de ce nouveau régime
unique agirc arrco et dont on redéfinit
tous les paramètres et dans cet accord
de 2015 il était prévu un retour à
meilleure fortune
lorsque les choses s'améliorent bien ça
s'est amélioré
financièrement donc on discute on veut
qu avec le patronat on rediscute de
cette oeuvre de cette disposition
un mot sur les ordonnances de revenir
sur le malus mais il est toujours
possible quand vous gérez un système de
faire évoluer les règles si la situation
financière et c'est le cas et meilleure
audi d'accord 11 ans je vois pas
pourquoi le patronat serait très ouvert
quand il ya un problème financier avec
faire illusion de gestion difficile pour
les salariés et les futurs retraités
et puis lorsque la situation va mieux et
il resterait sur ces dispositions non il
était prévu dans cet accord je le
rappelle une revoyure d'accord qu'alors
le 1er janvier qui ont eu un bonus d'un
malus de 10% sur les retraites
complémentaires ils vont faire la tête
des donc sauf si vous derozan ils sont
passés au mauvais moment si vous revenez
pour eux oui les ordonnanceurs réformant
le code du travail instaure un plafond
pour les indemnités pourtant plusieurs
décisions récentes ont vu des juges des
prud'hommes accordée aux salariés des
indemnités supérieures au plafond
instauré par ces ordonnances est ce que
vous vous réjouissez de cette décision
oui oui parce que c'est la démonstration
de ce qu'on disait c'est moi j'étais
contre cette disposition je me suis fait
même combattu j'ai même obtenu
on a même obtenu la cvt plusieurs fois
qu'elle soit remise en cause puis
finalement il s'est passé les
ordonnances pourquoi on était côte est
contre parce que c'est la réparation
d'un préjudice on parle de la réparation
d'un préjudice
je me suis fait virer de façon
illégal eh bien j'ai eu un préjudice je
le répare et donc là certains autres
certain nombre de conseils des
prud'hommes sont en train de faire la
démonstration bah oui que la réparation
du préjudice à peut pas rentrer dans un
plafond
donc maintenant on va voir ce qui va
comment cette chose là va prospérer
mais on voit bien il ya une baisse du
recours au barème caduque
potentiellement oui parce que il ya une
baisse de recours aux prud'hommes
extrait assez forte pour quoi parce que
maintenant ça serait grand disant aux
prud'hommes tu pourrais pas avoir plus
que ça je te vire c'est pas forcément
dans des bonnes conditions etc
mais tu prends ça et puis tu t'en
contente de toute façon tu auras pas
plus et donc non la justice et passage
une autre on a une autre conception de
la justice qui aurait par un préjudice
et on le répare et bien sûr leur
intégrale sur un sujet très différents
est ce que vous nous confirmez ce qui
est écrit dans le livre le poète et le
tueur sur emmanuel macron écrit par
nicolas domenach et maurice szafran
voilà que vous avez contribué en 2015 a
dissuadé françois hollande de nommer
emmanuel macron à la tête d'un grand
ministère de l'économie et du travail
ce que vous aviez vous senti chez lui à
un manque de fibre sociale déjà
peut-être non moi j'ai dissuadé à
l'époque parce qu'on m'a demandé mon
avis j'ai dissuadé le prénom la
république de l'époque de considérer
qu'on pouvait mettre un ministère de
l'économie avec un ministère du travail
vous savez je suis très attaché au
travail à la reconnaissance des
travailleurs à la bonne conditions de
travail est très attaché aussi à des
politiques de l'emploi notamment ciblé
vers ce créneau le plus besoin et je
crois que on a besoin d'une économie
forte dans les ministères de l'économie
fort mais je plaide et mon manque c'est
le sens de mon engagement syndical pour
que le social le travail ne soit pas le
sous-produit de l'économie et donc à
livrer dont je pense
attendez je vais finir je pense je pense
très clairement que faire un seul grand
ministère de l'économie et du travail
c'est faire passer le travail sous les
radars au profit de l'économie
donc il en était de mon point de vue
hors de question d'accord et puis il y
avait l'homme l'homme l'homme macron
vous avez l'artiste est lui à partir du
moment où ils pouvaient très bien mais
le maquereau à ce moment-là veut dire
juste au travail j'ai la suppression et
je lui serais pas d'accord je n'avais
pas les moyens de les opposer mais
jouera donc non mais ne riez pas dire
c'est pas
l'apa la culture social j'en veux pas ça
monsieur macron quand il était à
l'économie on a discuté du travail du
dimanche
je vais vous raconter cette histoire
j'ai passé dans le livre et à ce moment
là il y avait deux postures position y
avait une position de dire légale du
travail du dimanche et la loi fixe les
contreparties pour les salariés y avait
même des députés frondeurs qui à ce
moment là disait oui il faut fixer des
contreparties pour les salariés
20% 25% de plus quand ils travailleront
dimanche et nous l'a dit non voilée
c'est ça la négociation accord et si la
négociation si accord il ya ouverture
les salariés aujourd'hui il bénéficie
dans ces accords la de prise en charge
de majoration de serrières de 100% et
donc oui il ya ce moment là mais ce
macron il a écouté le sens du dialogue
social dans l'entreprise
il a écouté la cfdt l'a bien fait
dernière question dernière question a su
lanceur carlos ghosn question est-ce
qu'il peut rester à la tête de renault
sachant qu'on a appris qu'il était
résident fiscal aux pays bas bah ça ça
pose un vrai sujet de citoyenneté et de
responsabilité citoyenne
c'est sur le problème de la situation de
monsieur ghosn moi je suis pour la
présomption d'innocence
donc tu sais rien je n'ai aucun élément
ha ha dont je préfère le dire je me
réjouis pas et comble estime néanmoins
des seuls 30 des organes est néanmoins
et surtout une espèce de vacance du
pouvoir au arnaud qui commence à devenir
problématique
ceci étant faut faire attention de
vilipender en permanence là moi j'ai pas
d'éléments sur ce qu'il sait pas par
contre résident fiscal aux pays bas oui
il ya un sujet merci beaucoup lui en
verger d'avoir été à verser aujourd'hui
au terme d'une journée vraiment très
chargé pour nous avec des rendez vous
politique le sport soit elle veut sans
doute vent soir à tous à la semaine
prochaine